foreign
[Music]
chaos at DC the Marvel competitor has
been trying to counter the MCU with its
own Universe of movies for many years
but even though some good movies have
been made in the process it never really
went that smoothly at the turn of the
year the film Branch was then properly
resurrected the so-called dceu will soon
become history and the new DCU is set to
change everything in this video you can
learn what DC projects await Us movie
fans in the near future we talk about
Superman Legacy Aquaman in the lost
kingdom the Batman 2 and many many more
it all starts with The Flash the movie
is particularly crucial for the future
of the DCU and the conclusion of the DC
EU as its Story paves the way for the
new Cinematic Universe the production of
this important movie went anything but
according to plan and caused major
issues for those responsible the main
culprit is lead actor Ezra Miller who in
recent years has not prioritized filming
The Flash and has caused a number of
private escapades thanks to the hard
work of the entire team it all worked
out in the end and director Andy
muschietti was able to finalize the
production the film's theatrical release
officially marks the introduction of the
Multiverse to DC movies and you can look
forward to appearances by Michael Keaton
and Ben Affleck as Batman Supergirl
played by Sasha Cali will also be making
her debut the movie is currently running
in theaters so what are you waiting for
call your friends for a movie night
so far rather unknown is the superhero
Blue Beetle who will celebrate his DCU
debut in the upcoming film of the same
name production has already been ongoing
since 2018 and will also Premiere this
summer after it was unclear for a while
whether the movie would actually make it
into the DCU although Blue Beetle has
been part of the comic book Universe
since 1939. you may not have heard of
the superhero even if you're a DC fan a
first trailer has already been released
and shows main character Jaime Reyes In
Action For the First Time Reyes gets his
superpowers from a blue Scarab that
connects to his spine and gives him a
flashy blue high-tech armor the initial
Euphoria over the Newfound Powers
quickly Fades however when Reyes
realizes that more people are after The
Mysterious Scarab including main
antagonist Victoria cord and Conrad
karapaks we are excited to learn how the
new superhero in his origin story will
be received by audiences and look
forward to the theatrical release on
August 18 2023
for DC the year 2023 comes to an end
with Aquaman and the lost kingdom in
December the movie continues the story
of Arthur Curry played by Jason Momoa at
the same time it will also be brought to
its conclusion after the superhero was
introduced in the successful Aquaman
from 2018. According to director James
Wan the story about the Charming king of
Atlantis is largely based on the 1960s
comic planet of the vampires and will
also include horror elements for the
first time since the beginning of the DC
Universe but there will also be plenty
of emotional events in the sequel as
Arthur's brother orm will no longer be a
villain but a supporter in the fight
against Black Manta the latter will also
be assisted by conspiracy theorist
Stephen Shin who will be played by
Randall Park filming on Aquaman and the
lost kingdom has been completed for
quite some time now but the test
screenings that have taken place so far
have not generated a lot of excitement
among viewers it is also worth
mentioning here that Amber Heard will
make another appearance as Mira whether
the final result will manage to excite
DC fans as it did with the first part
remains to be seen the theatrical
release of Aquaman and the lost kingdom
is slated for December 20th 2023.
next year the sequel to The equally
successful Joker will be released after
the dark hit of 2019 many are eagerly
awaiting the continuation of Arthur
fleck's story we'll now get Top Class
support after the first part told us
about how Arthur became the Joker Dr
Harley and quinzel will now undergo her
transformation into a villain she is
initially Arthur's attending physician
at the famous Arkham Asylum and becomes
so captivated by him that she falls in
love with him and thus becomes Harley
Quinn the special thing about Joker 2
falia do however is a different aspect
because the production is supposed to
contain musical elements in large Parts
thus the sequel breaks new stylistic
ground although the environment will
surely be just as gloomy as in the
original in addition to Joaquin
Phoenix's Arthur Flack and Lady Gaga's
Harley Quinn zazzy Bates will also
return as Sophie Arthur's single parent
neighbor with whom he has made up a
complex Love Story although he has only
met her once in an elevator the release
date of Joker felia do is scheduled for
October 4th 2024.
in a little more than two years there
will be a reboot to a very well-known
character of TC we're referring to
Superman Legacy the first feature film
of the new GCU after crowd favorite
Henry Cavill played the role in Men of
Steel Batman v Superman Justice League
and Black Adam a younger actor will now
take his place still Superman Legacy is
not supposed to be an origin story as
such instead it will show how Clark Kent
balances his roots on the Planet Krypton
with his life on Earth where he works as
a reporter for the Daily Planet one of
the most exciting questions before
release will be who exactly will assume
the role of the younger Superman so far
several actors are being considered
including Netflix star David cornswet
grantchester actor Tom Brittany and the
still rather inexperienced Andrew
Richardson also under discussion is the
signing of Nicholas Holt who most
recently had roles in Renfield in the
menu to date it is not apparent which
candidate will be chosen by those
responsible another new character will
be Superman's animal companion Krypto
the super dog like his master he also
comes from Krypton and it's so far
appeared in DC League of super pads and
the Animated Series Krypto the Superdog
he has similar Powers as his master
which is why the two will certainly form
a strong team DC boss and Guardians of
the Galaxy Mastermind James Gunn will
direct the project we can't wait to see
what the 56 year old comes up with for
the movie Superman Legacy is expected to
arrive in theaters on July 11 2025
similar to joke or two the Batman 2 is
part of the so-called DC else worlds and
is not connected to other DCU movies in
terms of plot in 2021 the Batman gave us
a dark introduction to the life of Bruce
Wayne lexmore is a detective than a
superhero and fights some fearsome as
well as powerful opponents in part two
we will surely see some more returning
cast members besides Robert Pattinson as
The Dark Knight although little info is
known about the mess of yet at least a
comeback of Zoe Kravitz as Catwoman and
Jeffrey Wright as Commissioner Gordon
looks very likely since both had a
notable share of screen time in the
predecessor really not much is known
about the exact plot yet according to
current rumors however not only will the
villain Clayface be involved but the
comic no man's land will also be adapted
for the big screen this comic dates back
to 1999 and shows Gotham City sinking
into total chaos after a devastating
earthquake and having to be evacuated
the story is divided into different
storylines in which many familiar
characters want to gain control over the
practically deserted City more d
detailed information will be available
after the release of the Penguin series
which is supposed to link the story
between the Batman and its sequel the
theatrical release of the Batman 2 which
will again be directed by Matt Reeves
will be on October 3rd 2025.
at the beginning of the year James Gunn
announced a new movie for the DCU
Supergirl woman of tomorrow unlike her
much better known counterpart Superman
she grew up on the Planet Krypton and
only found her way to Earth much later
according to Gunn's statements Supergirl
will be significantly stronger and more
powerful than previous versions of the
character in the upcoming movie at the
moment there is no concrete information
on the casting of the superheroine it is
not clear at all whether Sasha Cali will
reprise her role from The Flash or if
she will leave right along with the dceu
details about the story or release date
are also unknown right now nevertheless
we are looking forward to the new
version of Supergirl and will keep you
up to date on any news
a new actor Will slip into the clothes
of Bruce Wayne AKA Batman unlike Robert
Pattinson's version of the character the
new Batman movie will be part of the DCU
and delve deeper into Bruce's family
backstory this will introduce an
interesting character to the Cinematic
Universe in the form of Damian Wayne the
Son Of The Dark Knight Damian is one of
the many versions of Robin the companion
of Batman he will certainly provide some
interesting moments with the odd
father-son Duo as soon as there's more
detailed information about the project
we will of course let you know
in addition to the projects discussed so
far there are other films in development
that will be part of the DCU we can look
forward to the Authority for example
which introduces a somewhat unusual
superhero team into the movie Universe
the main characters enjoy using extreme
methods to achieve their goals and are
said to be comparable to the popular
Amazon series the boys then things get
rather spooky in the movie Swamp Thing
which gets to the bottom of the story of
a mysterious Creature from the swamp a
number of series will be released and
incorporated into the DCU as well such
as Creature Commandos the spin-off
series Waller Booster Gold Paradise Lost
and the Green Lantern series lanterns
we hope you enjoyed our overview of
upcoming DC projects and would
appreciate your thumbs up also let us
know in the comments which of the
upcoming DC projects you're looking
forward to the most and why thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]
thank you